عكس ما كانت تشتهيه الاداره الامريكيه
سمحت البرازيل لسفينتين حربيتين ايرانيتين
بالرسو في ميناء
وجاء في اشعار نشر في جريده رسميه
برازيليه ان السفينتين وهما الفرقات دانا
ومكاران ستمكثان في ميناء
قائد البحريه الايراني الادميرال شهرام
ايران قال ان تنقل السفينتين جزء من مخطط
الوجود العسكري للقوات البحريه الايرانيه
في المحيطات وفي يناير الماضي رصدت
السفينتان من قبل القوات الفرنسيه
والاستراليه اثناء عبورهما جنوب المحيط
الهادئ وبعد البرازيل ستغادر السفينتان
الى امريكا الوسطى لعبور قناه بنما يذكر
انه سبق لايران وفي عده مناسبات ارسال
ناقلات النفط وسفن تجاريه بحراسه بوارجها
الحربيه عبر المحيط الاطلسي البحر
الكاريبي الى فنزويلا الخاضعه ايضا لحصار
امريكي الوجود العسكري الايراني في قناه
بنما الدوليه ووفقا لتقارير سيكون تحولا
نوعيا لظهران في مواجهه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والعقوبات الاقتصاديه من خلال
اقامه شبكه علاقات بامريكا اللاتينيه اما
السفينه تانى مكارا ويبلغ طولها 236 مترا
هي ناقله نفط تم تحويلها الى حامله تسعه
تسع خمسه مروحيات لتقديم الدعم اللوجيسي
في المعالق على الرغم من انها ليست سفينه
قتاليه الا انها اكبر سفينه حربيه ايرانيه
اما الفرقاه دانا فعدد طاقمها 148 محارا
وطولها سته وثمانون مترا انتهى تصنيعها
وادراجها قبل اقل من عامين في الاسطول
المكون من 86 قطعه مزوده بصواريخ كروز
مضاده للسفن وبتربيدات ومدافع بحريه وسبعه
زوارق عاليه السرعه وبطاقه من قد يزيد عن
200 بحار وقال قائد البحريه الايراني
السابق انه يمكن لسطحها صعاب ست الى سبع
مروحيات